[Music]
so doing a bit of organizing and I came
across a pile of 900 paper and in it I
have a while that I labeled study
manuscripts and I reminded me of a
practice that I used to do which is to
copy out scores we started off when one
my teacher recommended that I unbox
pieces and write it out in hoping for
then I started doing this for quite a
few places and write it up directly copy
what's on score in my own writing of
mana and this was during a period of
time when I was learning how to study
scores of learning how to practice and
I'm very aware that my level and scale
and studying score was very very low and
it's something that I'm still working on
every day this process really helped me
kind of slow everything down then we get
all the little details that I just
glossed over before there's something
about drawing in a slur drawing in an
accent stemming note that really helped
you notice them as I was writing them
self I would notice her patterns details
in in the way the lines are moving inner
lines that I never pay attention to
before these types of things so I
definitely recommend it but not too much
because it is it's a lot of time to to
write this out in my opinion just to try
it out for a few scores is more than
enough
I've set you on track to look at scores
differently so let's try to copy that
out by memory so I did roughly a page or
so and I'm checking it with the score
and right off the bat this Prelude is in
3/4 but I wrote it in 4/4
so with that air in mind I'm going to
check the rest of the notes and the ties
and everything so the G sharp is not a
quarter note so this F sharp is actually
held this is only an eighth note of the
rest here so that I have to do this to
find out that it's in three four not
four four and be sure of all the note
values no buts